oh we're bloody funny aren't we comedy
go
alright well today we're doing a verb
Lenovo video this time it's the ThinkPad
tablet check that out it's the limited
edition space lab one two wait are we
gonna shut water on this one as well now
that's old hat and also it's freezing so
we're gonna do a little challenge
between the both of us this tablet has
an absolute bomb load of features and
one of the cool ones is that it will
actually convert your handwriting into
text using this little pen so do you
have to use a pen with this
nope you can use fingers you use
anything actually pretty more
importantly can you play on your budget
yeah okay
so here we are at our challenge area
right so we have to run from here over
there
yeah across the gun whilst writing with
this pen on the ThinkPad I hope various
explosions a famous quote from the
ground of evident herb there's
explosions various expose another
various explosions yeah now that doesn't
sound very hard to be honest doesn't
does it make a pretty lame video as well
so we're gonna be blindfolded and pelted
with exercise balls so what happens to
the loser of the change funny should ask
the loser of the challenge has to hold
up the tablet while it's shot with this
whoa fully loaded people go I've really
bad handwriting as well yeah the winner
is the one who has the closest match to
the target sentence these are designed
to absorb shock and you know drops
pretty well I wish the safe reset for us
actually yeah
trying to restrict blood flow to my
brain a little bit I think I have a
better chance of winning if your Bloods
off yeah
[Music]
well dad I'm not gonna lie to you I'm in
pain yeah all over scratches bruises the
head hurts I'm winded from my spinal
impact on the ground painful
alright let's look at the results here's
mine it hits you first up that's not bad
that isn't bad I heard and ver from
various that's where you got hit by bull
it must have been yeah cuz I got I heard
that bang hit Bible immediately in this
bit I guess is they just all what the
hell
click the tablets one through the air
that way yeah let's look at my oh yeah
oh look you've got HRD from heard and
that's the listeners are there in the
right place why did you do that in
capitals and then the rest I passed out
after they hit the head I forgot my
which applications like yeah yeah if I
hit the head no ok so there's an X in
there though oh that's good at least
that's in the letter do you manage to go
that so it looks like I'm gonna be the
one holding this when we shoot it now
these ThinkPad tablets are designed with
special gorilla glass on the front which
is very hard to break very tough tough
enough to withstand one of these well we
got to find out I think we should shoot
the back first see if it works and then
nail the front it just appears
immediately as soon as I press the trees
laughs oh and then as you that little
shell the people really hurt right so
this one that's at 5,000 frames a second
slightly closer in rad I'm even more
scared than I was
you ready yep yeah keep your eyes open
bang alright so this is 200 and a bit
times lower
check out my oak and I hit you like oh
my
that's Kali oh no my finger again that
finger it's like the catchment it's
still just exposed so quick yeah it's
quite painless for that let's nail the
front screaming break good alright let's
get one more settle because I'm not for
that
[Music]
check it out didn't break I didn't
figure what it's good gorillas hard at
work
no one is gorillas like microscopic
gorillas in the glass really just going
like like punchin people's not true
obviously here we go in there
Angry Birds Angry Birds alright don't
about Angry Birds oh it's okay amazed it
works buttons yep top-notch so if you're
constantly getting hassled by paintballs
or rogue exercise balls as you do this
is the tablet for you comes with a noise
cancelling pair of headphones and a
sling as well they're sort of carrying
it yes job done I reckon
[Music]
you did it yes